you paid attention to every freaking
detail
when people say don't sweat the small
stuff sweat everything
every little detail matters everything
you ever thought you would not make it
through
you got past it now if you're currently
going through something right now guess
what you're gonna get past that too it
always works that way you always do
manage time
manage Focus so what happens is when you
try to when you try to manage time
the clock is always against you you're
trying to finish off something and time
goes by so quickly when you're in that
moment when you're so focused when
you're so focused you don't know if
you've been added for it
30 minutes or you've been at it for an
hour will you just go time creates
distractions literally time if you're
like managing time you get all these
distractions that are going there
what does Focus do it blocks them out so
don't worry about managing time manage
your focus be in that moment when you're
in that moment and then you'll get so
much more done during that time you know
time tells you to stop Focus tells you
keep going when you focus what do you do
you just keep going you just keep going
you just keep going you have to make
sure that your dreams
your aspirations and goals are so big
that not accomplishing them is not an
option
it's just not an obstacle
through all the things I've gone through
in my life I've had a lot of a lot of
downs how did I keep the faith it was a
couple of reasons I know from living
that if you quit
whatever you're trying to accomplish can
never happen there's not even a remote
possibility
if you quit there is no chance of it
popping back up again coming back later
quitting is guaranteed failure now when
you're trying you're going to fail that
was the number one thing I understood
and then number two
you have to watch something so big
that it wakes you up in the middle of
the night you have to want something so
big that you think about it all the time
you have to want something so big that
it drives you to wake up when you don't
want to it keeps you up at night when
you long been sleepy it makes you show
up do things you wouldn't normally do it
requires extra
if you want to be extraordinary and not
ordinary if you want to be ordinary live
your life but if you want to be
extraordinary you have to be extra if
you put extra on top of ordinary that
word is extraordinary it requires an
extra effort I think it's smart to focus
on one thing primarily because I'm too
many can be overwhelming other people
it's good to focus on multiple things it
depends on your personality so I
wouldn't presuppose but then the answer
would be whichever thing your most
desirest of changing what everything is
giving you the most pain if you change
the body you'll change the emotions you
could change the emotions you'll change
your decisions you'll change the quality
of your life because the quality of life
is your emotions
is that what you get and you have a
billion dollars and commit suicide
people have done it right you can have
beautiful relationships and commit
suicide you can have people loving you
and be sad all the time our pattern of
emotion is our home
and you have to upgrade your home
you have to train it and one way to
train it is the emotion comes the way
you move the way you breathe the way you
speak you have to understand why you're
going through
the period that's causing you to make
you want to give up
see the devil the devil has one mission
One mission only is to rob you of your
destiny that's the devil's only job
if he can get you to give up you have
been robbed of your destiny
if he can get you to become a criminal
he robs you of your destiny if he gets
you to never follow your dream Chase
your dream he robs you of your destiny
if he causes you to think that this is
all my life is
he has caused you to rob you of your
destiny when you have thoughts that are
negative that's not God that's Satan
he's doing everything he can to keep you
from being who God made you to be you
got to get focused man you got to
understand that this hard time that
you're going through everything you're
going through is preparing you for what
you what you ask God for you cannot name
one single thing
that God has not brought you through if
he hasn't brought you through it he's
currently pulling you through it right
now imagination is everything it's a
preview to Life's Coming Attraction
everything you've ever imagined is real
see I tell young people like this first
of all this is how your imagination
works you got to grab this concept it is
impossible for you to think an
impossible thought that is impossible
you can't think something that ain't
possible you ain't that smart
so if it's in your head you gotta ask
yourself how did it get there
that's God showing you a preview of a
Coming Attraction he has for you what
happens is through your childhood and he
may be on even later in life something
happens to you there's there's some kind
of decision you have to make there's
some kind of obstacle that came in your
way something that you have to deal with
and how you dealt with that situation
pretty much determines how everything
else is going to go did somebody handle
that for you or did you own up to it and
say I'm going to take I'm going to take
care of this I know those individuals if
you look at all their stories every
individual that spent successful you
know Bill Gates Jeff Bezos if you look
at everything that they've done some
kind of something happen in their life
early on in their life they put that in
this Relentless mindset to just be an
overachiever set unrealistic goals
because they saw something and they did
not want to go back in that direction so
when something happens you have two
options you can either curl up and just
say yeah you know make excuses after
excuses or you can own up to it and turn
around and figure out how to do it the
biggest problem people have is they
think they're not supposed to have any
and problems are the fuel for growth
right and so it's like you don't have
any problems you're either a liar or you
might call them challenges it feels
better I understand that but you know
anybody doesn't have problems he's
either totally asleep at the wheel or
they don't have much of any kind of a
life you know no responsibility nothing
they're building so I think the first
thing is this misnomer that if I have a
problem there's something wrong with me
or my life I think the second one is
this delusion we've sold people on that
getting what you want is going to make
you happy so you could call success
getting what you want I I don't Define
it that way but that's how most people
do but then there's fulfillment and
fulfillment is living What You're Made
for it's like I think the biggest
challenge people have and the reason
they're not able to respond to
challenges they're just thinking about
themselves and it's not that hard to
meet your own needs and it's nobody's
fault I mean these little things in our
pocket these little mini computers we
used to call phones
I mean they're constantly conditioning
you to instantly get what you want and
that's not how human relationship works
and that sure as hell not how you build
a business right it's not a straight
line and so I think the problem is that
people don't have something that they're
wanting to serve more than themselves
that's where my energy comes from I
don't have to work in a day in my life
and then I think the next problem is
that P
it the know-how I call it the Tyranny
about you get all excited I'm gonna do
this and then your brain goes I've never
done it before Oh my God what did I say
I don't know how to do this Martin
Luther King had no idea how when he did
his I Have a Dream speech in fact his
wife was the one that pushed him because
he was uncertain right you know the real
history is pretty interesting but the
bottom line is he gets up there and he
gives his vision of how it can be done
he talked about what needs to happen and
why if you can figure out what you want
and why you want it and you get strong
enough reasons reasons that'll drive you
late at night it'll get you up early in
the morning and the reasons are
different right so you gotta find your
reasons but if you know what you want
and you're good and big enough why now
you'll figure out how to do it but if
you start with how you know the small
brain the fear brain and I don't know
what to do I don't know where to go I
don't know what to do 90 of time either
I know what and why and then I try some
it doesn't work I try something else but
it's something else now I speed it up by
learning from the best so my life is
really about learn from the best but I
don't start with the hat I start with
the what and the why and I think that's
the mistake most people make good times
create weak people people weak people
create bad times bad times create strong
people strong people
create good times I like winning I like
being the best at what I do so I'm not
going to settle for less than that why
would I